Hello everyone, hope they are good.
Bitcoin just hit our target, 28,800.
If you remember the last Bitcoin update
on Friday, we were talking about this
specific level in the chart, 28,800,
because there were a lot of liquidations
showing in our block, okay? And we were
also talking about a day uh because in
this channel we care about timing also.
It's pointless if I tell you a target
and not when we're expecting that target
to get hit because then you don't know
when to trade, when to open a trade, and
then we're going to miss out.
You also need to have the confluence of
timing.
We were talking on Friday that we were
expecting some consolidation on Friday
and over the weekend.
That's the conclusion that we got to in
order to the next week, so this week, to
hit this target. Today is Tuesday. The
target has been hit. And you can see
here the consolidation from Friday and
over the weekend. And now they just
dumped the price there, okay? Why? Well,
the logic is here, okay? I think I've
already mentioned the logic in the
video, but I know that some of you might
be new into the channel. Welcome. But
usually when we see And this level,
okay, that's your low.
You guys know that always below the
previous lows there is liquidity here,
okay? Always. There is always liquidity
below previous lows and above previous
highs, always. Now, this zone we knew
there is a lot of liquidity, but
it makes more sense to consolidate
longer here, okay, and induce traders to
open longs. So, for example, here, here,
well, here too, and also here. What do
you see there? You see a spikes against
resistance and even going above it. Why?
That's to induce traders to open longs,
okay? Because the breakout traders are
going to think, "Oh, wait, this is a
deviation. We're getting above We're
getting back inside the range, then, you
know, we're going to go higher.
That's the game, okay? So, these are
your traps and during these traps what
they are basically doing is trapping
breakout traders that are longing here.
Why? Basically, to increase the
liquidity below, so when they come
lower, they're going to hit more
liquidation, so it's going to be a more
efficient move, okay? So, based on this,
let me mark it for you.
Uh
I think that the next target
of what I have mentioned this for a
couple of weeks, too,
is 20,337.
Why? Well, it's quite obvious. You might
have seen all this already from other
analysts cuz again, it's quite obvious
target.
This was a previous resistance that it
was tested tested twice, then price
rejects, and we haven't tested this zone
as a support yet, okay? Or at least for
now. So,
we're expecting price
to continue dropping
and target this zone.
Now,
because I'm quite focused on timing,
also, I'm quite obsessed with timing
because that's my confluence to open a
trade most of the time, okay? If I don't
have the timing in my favor,
I don't have enough confluence, guys.
So, putting together
my weekly psychological pattern together
and that I think there's going to be a
lot of bids here in this zone,
what am I expecting? Well, I'm
expecting, if you notice here, this is
your weekend range here, so let me mark
it for you.
This is your weekend range
over there,
okay?
Pretty boring.
Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom. Now,
price has started to drop at the start
of the week, okay? Possibly,
I'm naturally expecting this don't trend
to continue through today and tomorrow.
Okay? And then on Thursday
and I say Thursday because Thursdays
they mean midweek reversals for me.
Sometimes it can happen on Wednesday,
but they're usually on Thursday, okay?
I'm expecting
a reversal here likely because I know
that there are many traders opening
longs here. I would like to see price
dropping below it, deviate, get back out
of it, test it as a support, and then
we're going to aim for higher prices,
okay? Why this deviation? Because many
traders are going to open longs here.
They're going to have their stop losses
below this level.
Okay? So, that's when price could drop a
bit lower, hit those stop losses, then
reverse. So, on this way up
there is not going to be any long
traders, okay? Only the the ones that
have been waiting for this deviation.
And then once it is still support you
long. Okay? Uh could it could it bounce
from here? It could perfectly do, okay?
But
I would love to see a deviation, to be
honest, okay? So, I'm going to favor
this scenario for deviation here. Um
that's what I think.
Now
if we see something like this then over
the week let me move this it's on the
way.
If we see something like this, okay? You
see a drop, consolidate, continue
dropping, okay? Then on Thursday give me
a deviation, get back above it, test it
as a support possibly or at least make a
higher low, okay? And then you can pump.
Where to? Well, this one here is going
to act as resistance.
So, that's going to be around 29,100.
And if you get back above it then the
range slows, okay? 29,500 which is also
um
another big resistance. So, this is what
I'm expecting, something like this for
this week, okay? Also, there are not
many news announcements except on
Friday. We have non-farm payrolls, but
the good thing is that at the end of the
week, so it's not going to interfere
with our projection,
which I like, to be honest. So, maybe on
Friday we don't trade or we take maybe
one or two scalps max, but
during the rest of the week, if
something like this plays out, that
would be amazing, okay? For the traders
like us. Now,
let me remove all of this.
This is structure to me is looking
pretty bearish, okay? If we get this all
here,
they're going to see
how many times the range lows has been
tested as resistance.
Many times. If you check the 4-hour 50
MA,
you can see price is getting rejected at
50 EMA in the 4-hour time frame and it's
making all the time lower highs. Check
this out. Lower high. This is also a
lower high. Lower high. Lower high. All
the time. Now, we just made a new lower
low.
This is dropping.
Okay? I don't see any consolidation just
yet. This is in a downfall at least for
now. All right? So, again, I'm favoring
lower prices unless something changes in
the chart.
Now, if you want to the daily time
frame,
check out the 50 MA.
Madre mia,
as we say in Spanish.
Resistance, resistance, resistance,
resistance, resistance, resistance,
resistance, resistance.
And now it's going to be the dropping.
Okay? Way too much resistance here. You
got the 50 MA
and you got the range lows. So, I can't
be bullish here, okay? I'm naturally
expecting
this target here to get hit. Maybe we
see a deviation here and that would be a
nice long, okay? Otherwise, if we lose
this level, then
they're going to get back inside the
range and continue dropping to maybe
25,100
to the range lows.
Okay?
But again, we're going to go level by
level, support by support. So, for now,
we're only looking at the idea of price
coming lower. Hopefully that be it, and
then
get back above these zones. All right?
That's what we're looking for. But if
price continues dropping,
that's your next target. All right? I
hope that was clear. Now, for day
traders, let's go into the 1-hour time
frame. Let's see what it's
going on here, okay? Let's mark the
sessions.
I've already had a look at this, to be
honest. This is Asia.
Okay? Beautiful drop.
Now, London
seems that it might be holding here. I
know that some of you, based on the
trading session strategy, you might be
thinking
Asia drops, London holds, and New York
pumps.
Well,
there is something I don't like here.
And it's something that I've mentioned
before.
When you see a drop in the Asian
session, you want to see London holding
at the lows. Okay? Do you want to see
London
holding here.
Why?
Because if it holds here, then New York
has the chance of reversing
a lot more of a space. Okay? Check this
out. This is would be pretty much a 2%
move. Yeah, there you go. 2% move, okay?
Now, the problem is that you have London
holding
all the way up here. So, they've already
retraced part of this dump, okay?
Which is something that I don't really
like, because we don't have that much
room to the upside now.
All right? So, this is not a trade that
I'm going to take during the New York
session. I'm not going to long here
in the New York session. It might get
there,
but
to me, it's not as a high probability
trade as if London would be holding at
the lows. Okay? Because if If is holding
at the lows, then you would open a long
here and then you would have another
limit order here
in case there is a sweep of the lows and
then price can get back up and your
average entry would be around here.
Okay? And not here.
But having London holding already
I would probably saving 40% of this
drop. Okay? I think they've already
retraced 40% of this drop.
So, it's not as interesting trade for
me.
It's not worth it for me. Okay? So, I'm
going to be looking at altcoins. I'm
going to be looking at the 5-minute
timeframe,
15-minute timeframe, and I'm going to be
looking for a scalp. So, I'm not going
to favor a direction in the in today's
New York session. And even more
when I think
that during today
and tomorrow it's possible that we come
even lower.
Okay?
Uh this is simply not what I want to see
in the candlesticks. Okay? Again, if you
would have seen
London holding here, I would tell you
clearly, yes.
This is a textbook pattern.
We're going to retrace this dump.
Okay? But it's looking a bit different
to me. Now,
let's go into the daily timeframe.
Just
uh a quick update because I know that
crypto Twitter is
very bullish here.
Which uh I think it's normal because you
come from all of this drop here.
Okay? From 69,420,
you have all this drop to 15K. Then
price has done a times two.
Okay? And people are expecting price to
continue going higher, which is fair.
Okay? But I have a problem here and is
that we're in the pre-halving year.
The halving
um it's a cycle that happens every 4
years. Um the next halving is expected
to take place in a spring of 2024.
Now, this year, 2023, is the pre-halving
year, and in every pre-halving year,
the second part of the pre-halving year
is bearish, okay? That's what the cycle
says. If you go back in the chart,
you're going to notice, okay? The second
part of each pre-halving year is quite
bearish. And it wouldn't surprise me
also matching with the recession a
scenario that we see price heading lower
first, okay? Uh it's something that I
don't dismiss. Also, there is a lot of
imbalance in the chart, here, here,
here.
Uh to be frank, even lower, okay? But
we're going to go level by level. I
think that it's likely that
or it wouldn't surprise me at least we
come all the way here. Also, if you're
going to the weekly time frame, what you
got here, you got a week, okay?
This week is not
filled yet, okay? But for that, first I
need to see
Bitcoin
falling
off
here, back inside this range, to
continue dropping, and then in the
weekly time frame, I want to see Bitcoin
losing the weekly 50 MA,
okay? Once it loses the 50 MA and we
lose the range lows,
then
this is 25K, I will tell you guys the
next target is exactly 20 20,730,
okay? But you can see that there is a
long, long way for that target. So, I'm
not going to be screaming about this
target. Could it happen? Yes. But we're
going to go level by level, support by
support, and there is it still a very
long way, so we might not even get
there, okay?
That's what I think. Let me remove all
of this. Now, we're going to go into
Highblock Capital. We're going to check
about the liquidity, but first, let me
check the dollar index. I haven't
checked it today.
All right.
What is going on here?
Wow.
Wow. All right. Support. Support.
Twice. You are waiting for a three tops
pattern with a deviation. Here it is.
Tested a support. You can check there.
Okay, how it tested a support. Pump. And
now it seems that we might close today
the daily candle above the 50 MA in the
daily time frame.
This is very bullish for the dollar
index, okay?
Really bullish.
Uh that's what I think.
I wouldn't be surprised. We could make I
could sell it here, continue pumping
again to 103, 104, okay? That would be
quite bad for Bitcoin. Uh
Again, it's it sounds like I'm I'm
bearish on crypto. I'm not. I spent the
whole day yesterday researching altcoins
because I want to buy altcoins for the
next bull market, but
I think that the moment might not have
arrived just yet, okay? Now, if any of
you haven't watched the video
that I posted yesterday, no, yesterday
no, on Sunday,
it's quite a long video. It's a
50-minute video.
That's the longest video of the channel,
but in my opinion, it's one of the best,
okay? Because we go
through the Bitcoin dominance, the total
three, total three versus Bitcoin. We
chart 12 altcoins and the potential buy
zones if the narrative that I'm
explaining
explaining in that video plays out. So,
if that narrative happens
and what I explain in the charts take
place,
then
I might be bearish until we get to those
levels, but once we get to those levels,
I'm going to be the most bullish
because I'm going to have a lot of fun
in the bull market with holding those
bags, okay?
Uh so, yesterday I spent the whole day
researching
altcoins. I might do more videos about
altcoins cuz I think that you guys liked
it. So, thank you for your support. Um
saying that, I see another imbalance in
the dollar index that takes you to
102.5. So, why not could get here this
week, guys? What do you think?
This got a big pump from the dollar
index, okay? It's almost a 1% pump. I
think it's quite far away, okay? I think
that we are, for example, going to get
here this week
to this level.
102.10.
I think it's likely that we see the
dollar index continue climbing here into
102.10. Now, I cannot really tell you
when I get here as long as we don't
clean this level over here, okay? But,
yeah, I think it's eventually going to
head towards this level over here, okay?
And that's going to be pretty bad for
Bitcoin.
That's what I think. Now, we're going to
go into Hyblock Capital.
We're in Hyblock Capital liquidation
levels, and what do we see here? Well,
to be honest, there is not much going
on. Look at this box at the right, okay?
They are pretty high at 29,300
and 29,800. Those are the nice spikes,
but to be honest, I don't see much going
on here.
What's the delta saying?
Less than $5 billion worth of short
liquidations. It's not that much, guys,
to be honest.
It's not that much, okay?
Maximum, we could even see a pump
towards this spike.
29,300, but
uh is that is that worth it for $5
billion?
I don't know what the market maker
thinks. I think
um this is pure speculation, okay? I
think it would be more intelligent to
continue dumping price
to hit this short liquidation. So, you
mean this long liquidation, sorry. So,
the delta would increase maybe to $10
billion, maybe.
And maybe that's more likely to see a
reversal, okay? But again, no much It's
not telling me much.
That's only speculating. Now, if you go
into Hyblock Capital,
let's get to the 7-day time frame cuz I
want to see those liquidations. I can
already see it. Look at that.
Look at that. You see this yellow bar?
28,800 hit.
Okay, perfectly. Look at that how they
take all of this zone.
Okay? And now there is some liquidity
around 28,250,
which matches with our target.
But also to the upside, okay? So, the
liquidations heat map in the 70s time
frame is not really much because we are
right now between two liquidation zones.
But
in the 1-month time frame
this might be a little more clear. Let's
see this.
Okay, we just hit 28,700. There you go.
Um
I think this zone here is closer 27,800.
No much.
Nope.
And 3-month time frame
this is more clear.
24,200.
I don't know if we're going to come
here, okay?
Um because I'm telling you first you
have here 28,200 to clean.
And then you got 25k.
Okay? So,
uh you still have two big supports
to go through before getting here. So,
when you see this in the liquidation
heat map, don't think that we're going
to get here immediately.
Okay? Because again, there is two big
supports here that we need to break
through first, okay? So, this is pretty
much the liquidation heat maps. Not much
going on for a change.
So, that's pretty much everything
regarding Bitcoin. I think I was quite
clear with my what I think that it might
happen today and also the rest of the
week. So, hope that it plays out. That
would be amazing. Uh that's I'm going to
stick to that unless something changes
in the charts, okay? But those are the
things that I believe that will happen
next, okay?
And now about the website, okay?
We only have two courses left, September
group two and October group two. The
rest are fully booked. And we only have
in September group two 12 places in
stock. And in October group two eight
places, okay? So that's a total of 20
places. Now,
if you are interested, go through the
website,
read through all the information because
it's very likely that these
courses get fully booked this week and
then I'm not going to open any more
for these dates, okay? The next ones are
going to be for November, which is quite
far away.
So, that's pretty much everything, guys.
This is the last warning.
I doubt that I'm going to mention the
courses again in the next videos because
I think that they're going to get full
fully booked this week. So, take this
as a last warning that to hurry up
because I think it's going to get booked
this week, okay? So, that's pretty much
everything, guys. Thank you so much for
your support.
And I'll see you in the next video.